you we usually talk on the night of the
finale but it's been a few days now
how are you doing being home with your
daughter
how is the feeling of just being back to
normal
man i feel amazing you know that every
day
especially in the jury house because in
the jury house you're in limbo you're
not playing the game but you're not at
home so you're just like in this
and so every day i was counting down i
just want to see her i just want to feel
her i just want to smell her just be in
her presence you know what i'm saying
and so to finally be here i'm just like
yes
this it was all worth it for this this
right here
what did she say to you about winning uh
america's favorite
she keep asking me where is the check
she want to check
okay she told me two things she said
mommy where is the check and two you
can't go back so
from her mouth i cannot go back okay
and that feeling of winning i mean i i
feel like this win was not just for you
it's for bailey you went into that house
used that platform to use your voice and
you were heard
so what is that feeling for you it feels
so
amazing i was in disbelief like as you
saw on my face
i did not expect that at all and so when
julie said my name it wasn't
like yay i did it it was more so like
this one is for
us like y'all we did it we made history
tonight and so it's just
it's such a good feeling and and it felt
even more amazing to know
that everybody was touched by it you
know i wasn't the only one ugly crying
we was all ugly crying it's not that big
i know when i talk to bailey too the
love between you two is so precious
i mean yeah what does what does she mean
to you
oh that's my girl like that is my sister
forever and it's so crazy because so
many people thought we were friends
outside of the house but that thing
grew and blossomed organically in the
big brother house we
literally started from the bottom and
worked our way up and when i tell you
that friendship is irreplaceable like
that's my girl
forever forever and when you're out of
the house now you're kind of learning
about some of the things we saw as fans
on the show and there's been some
trigger points
with some of the conversations that were
happening in there uh
one being with christmas i know you
tweeted out yesterday about it
um what are your thoughts i really want
to hear from you directly because it
impacted all of us
watching it and we want to know what the
impact it was on you to hear those kind
of words
from christmas you know it's unfortunate
and
christmas has admitted to being very
ignorant but i'm one of those people i
feel like it's 20 20. if you're still
claiming ignorance that's a choice
so you're choosing to be ignorant you
know what i'm saying but
like i told her there's always room for
education and there's always there's
always room for growth the problem is
do you want to be educated and you want
to be
do you want to grow but the vibe i get
from her is that she does not she's
perfectly comfortable and content
in the space that she's in and that's
unfortunate you know and
one of my interview questions coming out
before i went to jury was do i think my
house guests
were able to learn anything from my
speeches and i was like i hope so
but it's unfortunate to know that a lot
of them mocked my speeches and made fun
of my speeches so it lets me know it
went on a lot of their ears like it was
death to the images
it's the how was it for you in the house
the house was it was rough it was rough
you know there was
a lot of you can't come like you can
come this far but you can't cross this
path like you can't you know and the
only way that i would have been able
to get into those conversations and they
would have been temporary because the
alliance was already formed it did break
my heart finding out
that this alliance consisted of no
people of color at all whatsoever
and it excluded in which really made me
mad as well you get what i'm saying i
think
ian called it the um privileged
straight and able-bodied and that
really bothered him because he was like
why not me i'm a winner too why didn't i
get pulled in
kevin was bothered he came in third
place why didn't he get pulled in you
get what i'm saying was just
so many different factors to it and i
was just like we never
had a chance the only way we stood a
chance was to win something and that was
our downfall
we could not win anything that's why
week five
sucked so bad cause i was so close i was
so
close but then week six came and it was
like i can't touch me
can't touch kevin can't touch david now
what you gonna do
and they went after ian and it was just
it sucked it sucks because if
if i wouldn't have used that veto and if
david wouldn't have used his power
then it literally would have went caser
bailey
david me kevin
back to back and that's not that's so
that's terrible yeah yeah i could feel
your passion
you're still going through all the
emotions right now so i thought
why don't i say someone's name and tell
me what's the first thing that comes to
you
a word maybe a sentence your feelings
whatever it is
first person tyler um
[Laughter]
he's a competitor tyler is a competitor
he is a competitor
i believe that okay kevin
kevin um funny he's funny funny
he's fine interesting
david is definitely interesting
that's a good word i really like that
that works really well with him
uh nicole nicole um
i feel really sorry for her i feel
really sorry for her because there
there's a void there
and um some something is is missing
and i hope she's able to feel it yeah i
feel sorry
janelle girl
[Laughter]
girl i need a janelle to do prototype so
bad
oh the girl jeanette just girl girl she
left you guys clothes right she left you
some of her clothes
she did she did she was like we came to
shop at the janelle store
so we can wear stuff when you leave like
yeah
and finally cody
um
cody that's all i can say it's just how
do you
how do you no you gotta give me another
word give me another word
a full sentence on cody not just cody
i'm not taking just cody
um great student
he's a great student okay he's a great
student
derek did what i'm great i absolutely
love you and i i'm so happy that you won
and i hope you do you know and the
money's going to help in so many ways so
i'm so
so excited for you congratulations i
hope we see you again a big brother
again
thank you so much